last week valkyrie announced the arrival
of her new skincare line which claims to
prevent damage from blue light and the
internet collectively lost its mind
people began hating on her calling in a
scam and making jokes about the brand
all while criticizing rey's attachment
to it
so let's answer the question
what is going on with this skincare
brand and why is it one of the biggest
controversies the internet has seen
recently
[Music]
all right before i explain everything i
gotta remind you to hit subscribe hit
the notification bell like and comment
on this video
our globe is gonna catch you if you
don't know who valkyrie is did you not
watch our story of i highly recommend
you check it out the tl dr is a valkyrie
is an incredibly popular streamer
content creator and influencer
she's just really big basically so big
that she inked a deal with youtube
gaming to exclusively stream on their
platform co-owns 100 thieves and
allegedly sold one million dollars worth
of merch in a single day so as a
businesswoman and entrepreneur it would
make sense to take next steps and expand
your business and that's where the tweet
of october 17th begins our saga valkyrie
sent out a now deleted tweet that a
two-year project was going to culminate
in a reveal two days later that same day
a twitter account named reflect skin
tweeted that in two days reflect by
valkyrie was coming valkyrie then shared
her excitement in a reply so we were
waiting we were wondering what could
this be bray had become known for her
great big business moves and this could
be another one of those moments then on
october 19th it arrived reflect is a
skincare brand influencers create
skincare brands all the time honestly
for me it was not that surprising but
what made reflect different was its
purpose it wasn't anti-acne anti-aging
moisturizing or any of the usual stuff
meet reflect it's the skin care
collection that's for everyone who uses
a screen
it's designed to protect your skin
against blue light which is emitted from
all digital screens yes even the one
you're using right now reflect says it
is powered by blpf
re3 and other essentials for healthy and
protected skin the bottom line about
this brand is that it claims to protect
your skin from blue light damage
basically all of our electronic devices
that have a screen emit blue light
supposedly this can cause damage to your
skin in a variety of ways so it's
targeted towards her audience and people
who use a screen
gamers if you will which especially in
the pandemic is a lot of people and that
is where the drama started with the
claim that the skincare brand was going
to somehow protect you from blue light
damage this brand claims to prevent the
damage that your phone screen and
computer screen can create which for us
gamers sounds pretty enticing however
when the brand was announced to have
blue light protection as its defining
feature
the internet had a field day on october
19th some of ray's friends like quarter
jade and also rey's fans expressed their
public support for the brand but then
the negative attention started it was
non-stop criticism from all corners of
the internet people began calling it a
scam many people were quick to accuse
the brand of being based in
pseudoscience which for those of you who
are not familiar with these blue light
products like the glasses are pretty
routine criticisms of the entire market
people also began to point out that the
website had some disclaimers that made
things a little hard to believe
disclaimers like we are not responsible
if information made available on this
site is accurate complete or current the
tweets here are just a small example of
the backlash she received after her
brand launch i'm not trying to
exaggerate it was a lot it was a tsunami
of mockery people like foosley publicly
supported valkyrie's character basically
arguing that she's a good person never
intentionally tried to scam or hurt
anyone later valkyrie sent out a now
deleted tweet from an alt account that
read i was told to wait until tomorrow
to speak i'm also very confused after
some silence valkyrie tweeted out that
she was going to go live on youtube to
discuss the brand as well as friends and
social media i watched it live and
honestly y'all it was really hard to
watch
she explained her side of the story and
everything like that but she also said
that she'd been experiencing really bad
really dark thoughts during this time
how she explained the situation is kind
of all over the place but were able to
piece together a couple of main themes
ray said she first became involved with
reflect two years ago after a meeting
was set up through her talent agency
through uta which is the talent agency
that my agent works for joanna
and
claudia
found me
and
they had a meeting with me and they
asked me during that meeting if there
was something
that i was interested in
and so i
interested to make and so i i said i was
like well
um is there any like research on blue
light and how it can affect your skin
because i you know i don't really know
much about it and stuff and they said
that yeah we can do studies on it
claudia and joanna are the co-founders
of ideviation labs which is described on
reflex website as a quote women-led
strategic incubator that focuses on
collaborating with startups established
companies celebrities and influencers to
create signature beauty and lifestyle
brands it's not clear to what extent
they were involved with the brand but
valkyrie mentions them by name they're
also the only people listed in the who
we are section of reflex website
alongside rey but
back to the timeline rey gives us the
next six months
they ran their own studies
they did their own research with
their labs and their chemists i saw the
research
i i saw it with my own eyeballs and i
was really excited because
i thought it was ground bait breaking
research i thought
it was all
wonderful stuff it was excited i thought
it was really going to help not just
like me but like other people as well
ray also explained that she was under
the assumption that the research would
have been posted at launch on the
website however it wasn't when she asked
why this was the case ray said she was
told that it cannot be published so i go
to them asking first of all there's no
information on the website and we're
making a claim that doesn't have
information on the website okay they say
okay we'll put website we'll put
information on the website
i see the website it's only third party
information
i ask wait how come our studies aren't
going on the website well it's because
we need to protect like the information
we don't want it to get stolen and they
said people have to try the products and
they have to do peer reviews and the
more and more skin care products out
there for blue light are out there the
more it'll be fda or whatever gets to
prove it or something so as of now the
public cannot read anything that
supposedly proves that this product has
the preventative qualities it says it
does the rest of the live stream
consisted of the following she doesn't
need the money she prides herself on her
morals and her character she is bound by
a contract she is aware that she could
get sued she believes in the product but
doesn't want to be a part of it anymore
because the research cannot be posted
there were also sections of her talking
about the different levels of friend
support that she received and what she
appreciated from whom speaking
specifically to the science about blue
light here's a tick tock from someone
who has a phd and actually knows what
they're talking about even with a
big-ass monitor you would need days or
months to get the same blue light as 15
minutes of sun and if you do want to
protect against blue light from the sun
which honestly isn't a big issue for
most people these products still
probably won't do much the active
ingredients are antioxidants which could
potentially mop up the free radicals
that the light causes in your skin but
that's so much less effective than
blocking the blue light from getting
into your skin in the first place like a
sunscreen for that you'd use foundations
or tinted sunscreens which have iron
oxides in them and you probably have
antioxidants in your skincare already dr
dre is a dermatologist with a popular
youtube channel no no not that dr dre in
a video addressing the situation she
says that blue light does affect your
eyes and your sleep cycle in our eyes we
have something called retinal ganglion
cells that are exquisitely exquisitely
sensitive to blue light and those
retinal ganglion cells they modulate
physiologic processes outside of just
vision they signal to your brain to
control circadian rhythm melatonin and
your sleep cycle so the harmful impact
of staring at a computer screen is
actually more towards your eye health
and potentially your sleep cycle but
what dr dre doesn't realize that the rr
never drops if the grind doesn't stop
she also said that calling blpf a
sunscreen for the screen was misleading
and she dug into the idea that blpf is
just ingredients and that's not how blue
light protection works as dr dre pointed
out blpf isn't something that is an
achievable thing like a factor of
protection like spf aka sun protection
factor what this person is referring to
is
a batch of ingredients so ingredients
you know there's not a batch of
ingredients that equals spf
so there's not a batch of ingredients
that equals blue light protection yes
some ingredients are known to help with
these things but to say it's like spf it
just kind of misrepresents what spf is
in the first place it is a measure of
the final product's ability to protect
you
from a sunburn dr dre has citations in
the information section of your video
for those of you who want to read more
this video is already super long where
we've pretty much covered everything
that has to do with this this product is
out and it's available in places like
ulta and for those of you who don't know
ulta is a nationwide beauty supply store
rey has since deleted all of her
original tweets regarding the brand and
has removed any mention of reflect from
her bio so
what do we learn from this one there is
a difference between giving someone
valid criticism for something they did
endorse created whatever
versus bullying them on the internet and
some of you need to get your head on
straight about that two most likely
unless the studies she says are real and
she saw have the most revolutionary
science behind it which would be huge
you do not need to protect your skin
from your screens the sun emits uva rays
as well as blue light so wear your
sunscreen when you go out not when
you're at your computer screen three
sponsorships endorsements and projects
like this can be incredibly tricky you
have to be extremely diligent about the
product you're putting your name on and
if your fantasy is their fave promoting
them you have to be fully informed
before buying them listen i use
prescription acne medication every
single night and i've spent so much
money on skin care products i have spent
countless hours studying and researching
skin care from people like dr dre my
grandfather died of melanoma which is a
form of skin cancer skin care and the
science behind it can do amazing things
including literally saving lives but the
companies behind certain products can
and do prey on the uneducated and the
afraid
do your research
and i wish i could tell my younger self
that like you don't need to apply pounds
of makeup onto your face to hide your
acne because your skin's your largest
organ it protects you from so many
different things and i'm not going to
let someone who like thinks my redness
on my face or like my acne makes me like
less
than somehow like if you have acne out
there you are beautiful you are valid
every like in like i hate when people
call it imperfections because they're
not imperfections like that is the most
insulting thing you could say to your
skin
like i just you do you
enjoy your skin you don't have it
forever so